match de gala au stade du bout des coûts
de maurepas les bleus du sky rugby
recevait le leader à cergy pontoise dans
le championnat honneur
en première période les joueurs du val
d'oise inscrivent quatre pénalités pour
mener 12 à 0 les joueurs du sky
s'accroche et marque un essai transformé
juste avant la pause
on entame mal chômage qui sont cul dans
le s'adaptent mieux aux conditions
climatiques
du coup ils prennent le score très vite
et on court derrière on court derrière
depuis le début ils respectent bien les
consignes je pense nous on sort des
consignes rapidement donc du coup on se
met vite à la faute et il arrive à
scorer au point ils sont à 100% au pied
donc c'est dur en deuxième période les
saint quentinois reprennent la partie
avec de meilleures intentions après
plusieurs pénalités manquées
cergy-pontoise laisse le sky revenir
dans le match les bleus inscrivent deux
essais pour passer devant à une minute
de la fin de la rencontre
[Musique]
mais sur l'action suivante les noirs
validant le neuvième victoire en dix
matches sur cette percée score final à
17 à 13 il était presque à à une seconde
quoi une seconde de la fin et reprennent
l'avantagé à cannes et ses rages ah
ouais bah plaquages ratés c'est parti
cergy c'est la grosse équipe de la poule
premier quasiment invaincu
jamais vraiment mis en difficulté par
les équipes donc donc c'était une grosse
performance de notre part et c'est très
frustrant encore de nous retrouver à
part ce match les saint quentinois
pourront se consoler avec le point de
bonus défensif ils occupent désormais la
8e place du championnat juste devant la
zone de relégation